you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
the world health organization warns of a
health catastrophe without climate
action
as ministers clash over the energy
crisis we look at how other countries
are dealing with the demand on gas
environmental protesters barricade
themselves in tunnels to halt hs2
construction
and george clooney talks to sky news
about his hopes for cop 26.
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
now the repercussions of climate change
are already being felt right around the
world and now the world health
organization and 45 million health
professionals have warned against the
direct impact of carbon emissions and
rising temperatures on people's health
in a new report released in the last
couple of hours and ahead of the cop 26
climate summit in glasgow the who said
countries must set ambitious national
climate commitments if they're to
sustain a healthy and green recovery
from the covert 19 pandemic
putting the health argument really at
the center to accelerate the
negotiations at cop 26 in glasgow
this year so we all hope that this
recovery after copy 19 could incorporate
our health arguments because we are
convinced that the health health will be
the motivation to do much more and to
accelerate action on climate change
so let's take a look at some of the main
points from the report and it says that
air pollution is responsible for around
seven million deaths globally per year
with around 99 of the world's population
living in places where air quality
levels exceed who limits but bringing
down air pollution could reduce the
total number of global deaths by 80
percent
now globally one in five deaths are
associated with poor diets and the who
recommends that a shift for more
nutritious diets would prevent up to 5.1
million diet-related deaths a year by
2050
and extreme heat led to more than 365
000 deaths in 2019 and the wha warns
that that number will rise
well we can go now to ludwar in kenya
and our health correspondent ashish
joshi so ushish a pretty dramatic
warning from the who
just how much resonance will it have
where you are
oh you can see it everywhere anna the
warning by the who comes after it spends
time
in places like north kenya there's a
drought here it's a it's an arid area so
it's used to being dry the people here
have lived for generations with very
little water but in some places they're
telling me they haven't seen rainfall
since 2017 we visited a town near um a
big lake um
lake turkana in the north here it's a
saltwater lake a township which can't
use the the water from the lake because
it's saltwater lake so they rely on one
single river now this single river is
just a dry flat bed where children are
pouring holes into the ground to extract
fresh
water to drink
and there's a hundred thousand people
who live in this township who all rely
on these small bore holes in the ground
i spoke to women today
who work with separate schemes to try
and help them to earn new livelihoods
because they've lost all their cattle
they've lost all their sheep through
this drought there's nowhere to take
these animals out to pasture if you lose
your um if you lose your animals you
lose your livelihood so there is this
a real crisis which is building here two
and a half million people in kenya alone
are said to be um in danger of of
this food shortage and that's why the
kenyan government has taken action to
try and encourage large organizations
like the word food program like the
united nations to make interventions now
before this emergency turns into a
crisis
ashish thanks very much indeed
now wholesale natural gas prices remain
high today climbing by seven percent to
209 p per firm and well above the 40 to
60 pence range where gas has traded in
recent years now sky news understands
that the government has made a formal
request of the treasury to support
industries hit by high energy prices
well let me just take you over to our
data dashboard now and you can see up at
the top where the uk is getting its
energy from right now and you can see
that 55
is currently coming from fossil fuels
that's primarily gas we've got 31 there
coming from renewables and meanwhile
we've got 14
coming from nuclear
but that power mix differs depending on
where you are in the world skies science
correspondent thomas moore has been
looking at how decisions on energy have
affected other countries
the eye-watering spike in the cost of
gas is painful for consumers and
businesses this is the price of
wholesale gas and it's up more than 500
since the start of the year all
countries are facing the same
stratospheric surge in prices but when
it comes to generating electricity some
are better insulated against the impact
let's look at the uk's energy mix at
midday on monday gas made up almost 50
percent renewables around a quarter
nuclear a little over 10
and there's a little bit there from coal
too
compare that to last october and you can
see renewables are roughly the same but
we're using a lot more gas now and
that's to make up for a sharp drop in
nuclear generation as half a dozen
reactors have been shut down for
maintenance
it's a very different situation in
france there almost 80 percent of
electricity is generated with nuclear
energy gas makes up less than 10
significantly less than the uk so the
direct impact on electricity consumers
is much lower
france also generates enough energy to
export to other countries
germany also has a very different energy
mix to the uk just 13 of its electricity
was generated with gas at midday but
look at coal it made up almost a third
but germany's heavy use of coal comes
with a climate cost the dirtiest of all
the fossil fuels produces the equivalent
of around 800 grams of carbon dioxide
per kilowatt of energy that's twice as
much as gas for comparison offshore wind
is just 10 grams per kilowatt
coal just does not fit inside the carbon
budgets that we have and it doesn't fit
inside the international commitments
that we're signing up to
and on the economics point
it's cheaper than gas at the minute but
the lesson from the gas crisis should be
that fossil fuel prices are very fickle
very volatile
and coal could just as easily become
expensive another time so
rather than trying to
pick the least worst fossil fuel and
hoping it stays cheap
you should be trying to move away from
fossil fuels entirely back to homegrown
renewables
the energy crunch is worldwide india's
135 coal power stations which generate
70 percent of the country's electricity
have their own supply crisis
more than half have stocks to last just
three days with blackouts a growing
reality as economies are restarting
after the pandemic energy is in high
demand
in some of today's other climate news 24
countries including pakistan and japan
have joined the us and eu and committed
to reduce methane emissions by 30
percent by 2030 signing up to the global
methane pledge methane is the second
biggest cause of climate change after
carbon dioxide
china has promised to include
biodiversity in its economic plans on
the first day of the cop15 biodiversity
conference world leaders have gathered
virtually to discuss a framework for
slowing the loss of nature and species
ahead of face-to-face talks in china in
april next year
the solar flare is likely to hit earth
today which could disrupt power grids
and satellites the u.s national oceanic
and atmospheric administration has
issued an alert for a g2 geomagnetic
storm which means it's moderately strong
it could also boost the intensity of the
northern lights making them visible in
parts of england and new york
now security officers are trying to
remove environmental protesters from a
network of tunnels which have been
created to halt construction of the
high-speed 2 rail project and brady
reports from buckinghamshire
extraordinary security operation
underway at this wooded area on the
outskirts of wind over here in
buckinghamshire let me just show you
where the protesters now are so
they've managed to construct this kind
of makeshift tree camp if you will a
tower of pallets wooden pallets that
goes all the way up and there is a
ladder all the way down through the
middle of us and that then takes you
down
into the tunnels
the protesters supporters tell me that
there is a network of tunnels that they
have painstakingly created
over the past few months and there are
at least four people down there and
amongst them
a very well-known environmental activist
called swampy his real name is daniel
hooper 48 years of age he was actually
in court last week in numerous offenses
uh the judge threw them all out every
charge against him was dropped last week
and i'm told swampy was driven directly
from highbury magistrates court in north
london to here where he has gone
underground if we just pan around this
way i'll just show you this
extraordinary security operation if we
walk down a little bit i just want to
show you just how many security officers
there are here the whole way down these
are all private security officers there
are bailiffs here as well thames valley
police are here and british transport
police and this is day two of this
tunnel occupation as the protesters and
their supporters are calling it and they
say that they will try and do what they
did at houston station which was to stay
underground for a month and they say
they have supplies provisions and that
they will keep going
now we should warn you this next story
contains flashing images from the start
and with less than three weeks to go
before the cop26 conference in glasgow
george clooney says he's hopeful but not
optimistic that it will lead to much
progress speaking at the uk premiere of
his new film the tender bar the actor
said the climate summit stands better
chances of achieving something than u.s
congress does
listen to better chances here than you
know than we've had the united states
recently
because our congress
lives in a bit of a state of denial it
used to not be a political situation
nixon used to do something about this
quite honestly so i'm i'm disappointed
with the way and the directions that
our congress has gone
so i'm hopeful that more will be done
here
i think some will but i'm not i'm not
all that optimistic about it i don't
know i'd like to be i'm a pretty
optimistic
and coming up after the break we'll be
discussing how uk manufacturers are
urging the government to give workers
the necessary training to decarbonize
the sector a new report from make uk and
sage has found 92 percent of companies
believe they can reach net zero targets
by 2050 with the government's help
so my guess for that are emily shukra
from cambridge zero and dan caesar from
the fully charged show they'll be here
to discuss that and more that's coming
off after the break
[Music]
the government has got an ambitious
target that will reduce our emissions by
two-thirds by 2035
and businesses are a core part of that
so we've taken a look at the biggest
businesses in the uk
and we've disappointingly found that
only 19
have got a plan to reach net zero now
more of them have got a target and
that's welcome that we've got a target
but obviously what's really important is
that you've got a plan to meet that
target and as i say only 19
have made that plan and we can see that
plan so what we're calling for is the
government to to stop the gap and not
expect that they're going to get these
emissions reductions unless we have
legislation for plans and mandatory
transition plans in the run-up to the
landmark cop conference that we've got
coming up in glasgow in only a few weeks
time we've got businesses falling over
themselves to talk about net zero and as
i say there is a lot of commitments out
there but commitments are one thing a
plan is a very different thing you know
i compare it a bit like to a pizza box
there's calories on a pizza but it
doesn't mean to say you're going to stop
eating it or lose weight a weight
management plan is a very different
proposition and so whilst we do welcome
the companies that have come forward
with net zero commitments there are over
a quarter left in the foot so you
haven't and we'd urge them to come
forward with commitments we're also
saying we need that plan a government
needs to step in the window for
voluntary action has gone we all know
that the science is terrifying we've all
got to step up now and make sure we're
on that trajectory towards net zero with
credible plans alongside those credible
commitments
the government is saying this is their
big issue so if this is their big issue
and they're putting a plan on the table
and they want everybody to to put you
know to come on board and support them
doing that they need to set the criteria
in place and so we need legislation to
make sure there's a level playing field
and actually some of those leading
businesses are saying please do it
because at the moment we're all in this
sort of no man's land with various
commitments of different um ambition
levels and actually we all want to move
together if we move together you know
not only is that good for the climate
but it could be really good for the uk
there's a lot of business opportunities
for those who go first and go faster
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
did you know that driving us to school
creates extra toxic air at drop-off and
pick-up times
[Music]
there'll be a mainly dry morning with
sunny spells best in the southwest but
the cloudier north and east can expect a
little rain at times there'll be some
fog on northern coasts and hills
temperatures will be much like today's
the afternoon will bring little change
although northern and eastern england
will see patchy rain developing a bit
more widely we've got clean atlantic air
spreading from the northwest so the air
pollution index where one means low
pollution and 10 means very high will be
low everywhere
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with
director of cambridge zero and climate
scientist emily shukra and chief
executive of the fully charged show dan
caesar so welcome to both of you good to
see you both
so first of all net zero now we hear
that phrase from political and business
leaders every day it means reducing
carbon emissions by as much as possible
and then offsetting the rest and while a
growing number of companies have set
targets to reach net zero by 2050
fewer of them have released detailed
plans
so emily to you first of all the
government's asked companies to
voluntarily release their net zero plans
i think particularly they want to do it
ahead of cop but do you think it should
be mandatory
well i certainly think it's incredibly
important i mean first of all let's say
it's fantastic that increasing number of
businesses are starting to recognize the
importance of putting in place net zero
targets but then also about trying to
work out how they're going to actually
achieve those with actual detailed plans
from today because we need action today
and we need to understand what what can
be done today rather than off in the
distance uh off in the distant future so
i do think it's really important that
businesses you know do recognize the
challenge and then respond to it
well yes and it's interesting you say an
increasing number because the wwf
released some details that said that
only 19 of major uk companies they say
there we go have uh published a detailed
action plan for reaching net zero so dan
if you do
say force all companies to release a
plan do you also need that audited in
some way do you need the plans to be
seen to be credible and also for any
progress to be
to be monitored
well there are exceptions to every rule
of course but the moment companies
aren't doing enough and i agree with
emily it's great to see that so many
companies are taking it seriously but a
lot of companies are still indulging in
in green wash frankly so
you really can't rely on an industry to
police itself or investors to police
that industry either and that's why what
government says that cop 26 is going to
be so
important because they need to level the
playing field they need to be clear
on what we need to do next and it is
time for action and not words
so sorry dan you want the government to
sort of lay out parameters for
businesses do you is that is that what
you're calling on from them i think
governments in general yeah i wouldn't
even just say it's just a uk government
thing this is a global uh challenge but
i think uk government has a strong role
to play as we're hosting uh cop 26 and i
would like to see them go much much
further than they have done before in
terms of being clear on net zero and
what businesses particularly energy
intensive industries need to do next
well yes and there's a point there isn't
there um emily that different businesses
have very different needs in terms of
reaching net zero i think cambridge
university set out plans to reach net
zero by 2038 last year but that's a very
different prospect to a steel company or
an airline trying to get to net zero
oh absolutely so each different sector
is going to have its own his own
challenges i think one of the really
critical things though and you mentioned
a moment ago is that the need within
that net zero to do everything that you
can as a business to reduce your
emissions and leave offsetting really to
those aspects that that absolutely
cannot be reduced so one example would
be for example in terms of business
travel um you know if everyone was just
saying oh we're going to offset all our
business travel continue as normal
then we simply wouldn't have enough
offsets to go around
businesses need to be looking at how
they can cut reduce their emissions
travel less we're all doing it but you
know many business interactions
virtually instead um
at the moment because of the pandemic
that needs to be ingrained in terms of
normal business action that's just one
of a myriad of examples where the first
thing ought to be cutting our emissions
and then reserving offsetting only for
those things that really cannot be cut
so that's what business can do and going
back down to what you think governments
should do you talked about them setting
out frameworks what about also making
clear what their priorities are in the
future whether it's investing in green
hydrogen or green steel or carbon
capture does that make a difference to
businesses in knowing how to go about
making their own plans
it does and frankly there are a huge
amount of technologies on the table and
that's useful but it actually has become
less productive i would say there's more
options now than needed and some work
better than others so i think a more
focused approach i think if you're a fan
of renewables like i am you would
actually say that maybe things like
carbon capture uh and storage and uh
green hydrogen a little way off and we
should be focusing on focusing on the
now technologies like batteries uh wind
and solar and in terms of the energy
intensive stuff maybe we need to have a
really hard discussion as consumers as
people who consume about do we need to
consume as much steel glass paper etc
and i think that's the big question that
we should all be asking ourselves yeah
and we're talking a little bit about
consumers next actually because gas
prices continue to spike hitting levels
uh high levels for both consumers and
businesses but could the volatility of
gas prices push consumers to invest in
greener alternatives such as renewable
energy in the home emily do you think
this gas price rise obviously it's bad
news for consumers and businesses but is
there a possibility that it'll prompt a
change in behavior from individuals will
people think right i'm going to put
solar panels on now you know do you
think it could
push some kind of change
well i'm thinking you know basically
everyone would like to have clean
affordable energy without the sort of
price bikes that we've suddenly found
that we're all having to respond to um
as a result of having that big reliance
as we still currently do um in terms of
oil and gas for you know heating our
homes and powering our powering our
transport and renewable technologies you
know do offer an alternative but in
themselves they're they're not
sufficient because you might say well
what's going to happen if the wind
doesn't blow or the sun doesn't shine
aren't we similarly going to get those
price bikes so it absolutely needs to be
combined with investment in things like
smart grids to balance supply and demand
better but also in terms of energy
storage grid scale energy storage so
that we can store up um the energy when
the wind is blowing and then use it when
the wind is blowing less
you're nodding there dan
yeah it's really interesting i
completely agree what emily says i mean
my interest really is in the home uh and
and buildings i think and from my
perspective there are some more
expensive technologies and i think that
can um run the risk of actually making
people not want to participate but there
are cheaper things that can be done i
think from a consumer's perspective
there are some cheaper options and some
more expensive ones too well yeah and on
that i'm just going to take a look at a
statistic i found really interesting the
average cost of a solar panel system is
almost 6 000 pounds that's 50 cheaper
than 10 years ago so it's really
interesting how prices are coming down
but it's still a big outlay for an
individual isn't it
in the first instance we would actually
push people towards things that are easy
to do like insulation for example energy
efficiency measures maybe get a smart
thermostat uh look at which rooms you
need energy in and which ones that you
you don't aerated shower heads there are
some actual cheaper options and also
shopping around to buy uh renewable er
electricity from a supplier and then
there are some more expensive options as
well and i think things like heat pumps
and zero emission boilers are going to
play a huge role in this transition over
the next decade too we've we've got
about 10 seconds emily have you got one
little tip for consumers here
um
i'm going to let you off the hook next
time you come on i might revisit that
and give you a bit of a chance to think
we're out of time though emily and dan
really good to see you thanks very much
indeed
do stay with us we've got plenty more
coming up in just a moment including the
business secretary asked the treasury
for help as businesses struggle to cope
with soaring energy costs now derby
manhattan is up next he'll have all the
latest on that story on sky news tonight
and of course we'll be back again
tomorrow so do join us then thanks for
watching
[Music]
you